الله
[تصفيق]
اكبر استيقظ الاسرائيليون على كابوس يوم
السابع من اكتوبر هجوم لم يسبق له مثيل في
تاريخ الدوله العبريه اقتحم مئات
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين السياج الفاصله مع
قطاع
غزه خلال ساعات الهجوم والتمركز داخل
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه قتل
3119 عسكريا اسرائيليا وفق الاعلان الرسمي
الاسرائيلي من بين هؤلاء القتلى
68 من قوات حرس الحدود الاسرائيليه ومن
بين هؤلاء سبعه من قاده السرايا في الجيش
كل واحد منهم يقود على الارض سريه مكونه
من بين 60 الى 190 عسكريا بالاضافه الى
ذلك اربعه من قاده الفصائل يقود كل واحد
منهم ما بين 16 الى 44 عسكريا بالاضافه
الى ثمانيه من مسؤولي امن المستوطنات في
غلاف غزه حوليت نحال العوز بئيري عين هشلو
شاا م افتحي نير اسحاق فار عزه كل هذه
المناطق تم استهدافها ولكن الاهم كان
مستوطنه رعيم هذه المستوطنه مقر قياده
فرقه غزه في الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه
المستوطنه تتكون هذه الفرقه من لوائين
كانت مهمتهما حمايه الحدود بين قطاع غزه
اسرايل وفي السابع من اكتوبر تلقت هذه
الفرقه ضربه قاسيه اذ قالت كتائب القسام
ان الفرقه سقطت بالكامل واعترفت اسرائيل
لاحقا بمقتل قائد لواء بفرقه غزه واحتجاز
القسام جثمانه اثناء
العمليه الله
اكبر منذ ذلك اليوم وحتى بدء الهجوم البري
اتخذت الحرب نسقا واحدا من تبادل اطلاق
الن قصف اسرائيلي على كل مناطق قطاع غزه
قبله قصف من المقاومه الفلسطينيه نحو
اسرائيل بالتزامن مع حشد اسرائيل قواتها
على حدود قطاع غزه استعدادا للهجوم البري
بقي الامر على هذا الحال حتى السابع من
اكتوبر بدات القوات البريه الاسرائيليه
هجومها على قطاع غزه من محورين اساسيين
مستهد فه مدينه غزه بشكل اساسي من الجبهه
الشماليه الشرقيه من جهه بيت حانون ومن
الجبهه الشماليه من جهه بيت لاهيه ومن
الجبهه الشماليه الغربيه من جهه العطاطه
بالاضافه الى الجبهه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
من منطقه جحر الديك كل ذلك كان الهدف منه
تطويق مدينه غزه وسط او شماليه قطاع غزه
توغلت القوات الاسرائيليه في الايام
الاولى للهجوم البري ثم بدات الخسائر
في صفوف الجنود
الاسرائيليين بسم الله يا
رب استهدفت كتائب القسام جنود واليات
الجيش الاسرائيلي باسلحه متنوعه من قذائف
الياسين 105 والتي بي جي والعمل الفدائي
والاسلحه رشاشه والقناصه وعبوات شواظ وهنا
بدات خسائر الجيش الاسرائيلي بالتزايد
على امتداد 60 يوما من التوغل البري قتل
1882 ضابطا وجنديا اسرائيليا بمعدل ثلاثه
عسكريين كل يوم في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع
غزه الله
اك
اكلوها الله
اكبر بسم الله
الله تبدو ارقاما كبيره دون الغوص في
تفاصيلها لكن تحليل هذه الارقام يعطي صوره
عن الخساره التي تلقتها اسرائيل منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الاهم ان هذه الخساره
مضاعفه من حيث نوعيه القتلى منذ قرار
الاجتياح البري الذي لم ينتهي حتى الان
خلال فتره التحليل نفسها نجد ان الخساره
البشريه الاسرائيليه في الجيش تنوعت بين
الالويه والقوات
الخاصه بالنسبه للاليه من بين سته الويه
في الجيش الاسرائيلي تلقى خمسه خسارات
قاسيه ومتنوعه في الجنود والضباط خسر لواء
جفعاتي قائده سيريه بالاضافه الى اربعه من
قاده الفصائل و 29 جنديا بينما خسر لواء
المظليين قائدي سريتين وقائدي فصيلين
بالاضافه الى 25 جنديا خسر لواء النحال
قائد اللواء بالاضافه الى قائد كتيبه من
اربع كتائب وثلاثه من قاده السرايا وثلاثه
من قاده الفصائل و
28 جنديا الضربه الاقوى كانت من نصيب لواء
جولاني الذي خسر قائد غرفه عمليات اللواء
وقائده كتيبه وخمسه من قاده السرايا
وثمانيه من قاده الفصائل بالاضافه الى
1 جنديا في لواء النخبه كانت الخسارات
محدوده لكنها مهمه يتكون لواء الكوماندوز
البري من ثلاث وحدات هي ايجوز ودف دوفان و
جلان قتل من هذه الوحدات اربعه من قاده
السرايا وقائدا فصيلين و 21 جنديا كل
هؤلاء نخبه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذه الوحدات الثلاث ضمن لواء
الكوماندوز هي ايضا تتقاطع مع القوات
الخاصه الاسرائيليه اذ تتكون هذه القوات
من 11د ع وحده خاصه من بين الوحدات الخاصه
الا عش تلقت ست خسارات
قاسيه وحده سياره متكال هي وحده جمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الميدانيه التي
تجري استطلاعا عميقا خلف خطوط العدو
للحصول على معلومات استخباراتيه
استراتيجيه تم تكليف سياره متكال ايضا
بمكافحه الارهاب وانقاذ الرهائن خارج حدود
اسرائيل يتم تدريب الجنود المقبولين في
نصف السنه الاولى ضمن اطار سلاح مظليين ثم
يجتازون دوره خاصه في التنقيب والبحث عن
الجهات وتحديد الاماكن والذين يكملون
هاتين المرحلتين يقبلون نهائيا في الوحده
تلقت هذه الوحده ضربه قاسيه في نوفمبر عام
2018 عندما فشلت في الدخول الى خانيونس
جنوبيه قطاع غزه بعد ان اكتشفتها قوه من
كتائب القسام في الحرب الحاليه خسرت هذه
الوحده تسعه من جنودها وقائده سريه وحده
شلدا هي وحده قوات خاصه تحت قياده القوا
الجويه الاسرائيليه تعتبر واحده من اكثر
وحدات النخبه في جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
معظم عملياتها سريه قتل منها في قطاع غزه
ثمانيه جنود وقائدا فصيلين وقائد سريه اما
وحده الانقاذ الجوي او وحده 6 س ت فهي
وحده للانقاذ التكتيكي التابعه للقوات
الجويه الاسرائيليه قتل من هذه الوحده
الخاصه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه بغزه جندي
وقائد فصيل هكذا تكون اسرائيل قد خسرت 500
وعسكريا واحدا منذ السابع من اكتوبر بينهم
182 منذ بدء التوغل البري في الساا من
اكتوبر وحتى هذه الساعه من بين هؤلاء
القتلى
56 برتبه قائد فصيل و
43 برتبه قائد سريع وثمان
برتبه قائد كتيبه وخمسه برتبه قائد لواء
يشكل هؤلاء الضباط ما نسبته
23% من مجمل قتلى الجيش في الحرب على
غزه اما بالنسبه الى المصابين فالاعداد
مضاعفه بطبيعه الحال تقول الاحصائيات
الاسرائيليه ان
2159 عسكريا اصيبوا منذ السابع من اكتوبر
بينما اصيب
921 عسكريا منذ بدء التوغل البري من بين
هؤلاء 206 عسكريين في حاله الخطر الشديد
هكذا تتراكم اعداد القتلى والمصابين في
الجيش الاسرائيلي يوما بعد يوم هذا ما
تعترف به المؤسسه العسكريه وما تقول انه
سمح بنشره لكن المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
تتمرد في بعض الاحيان على قرار المؤسسه
العسكريه وتنشر تفاصيل اكبر بكثير عما
يتحدث عنه الجيش اعلنت صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت
عن ان الجيش خسر 5000 جندي اصيبوا في
معارك غزه بينهم اكثر من الفي معاق الامر
الذي اعترضت عليه الرقابه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وطالبت بحذف الخبر لتبقى
الحقيقه غامضه في اعداد من تخسرهم اسرائيل
في جيشها الذي لا يزال يقاتل في قطاع
غزه